des radiateurs de locomotive découpé à
la disqueuse un mode opératoire
particulier qui intrigue les gendarmes
après huit mois d'investigations les
enquêteurs mettent au jour un vaste
réseau criminels opérant sur l'ensemble
du territoire
principale région touchée l'île de
france les pays de loire les hôtes
france le grand est et bien sûr la
bourgogne franche comté cible
privilégiée de ce réseau le cuivre
présents en grandes quantités dans des
zones peu surveillés ils se revend plus
de 5 euros le kilo un radiateur volet se
négocie à plus de 250 euros l'unité
confiée à la section de recherches de la
gendarmerie de dijon
l' enquête va aboutir le 22 septembre à
l'interpellation de onze individus
l'enquète doit permettre maintenant
d'identifier des complices de cette
organisation et éventuellement de les
arrêter si possible évidemment quoi et
de mettre vraiment à terme à ce
phénomène sérielle qui a été commise sur
je vous le rappelle l'intégralité du
territoire national la justice a demandé
quatre cent mille euros de caution pour
les receleurs
c'est dire la puissance de ce réseau de
malfaiteurs roumain depuis le début de
l'année 2010 9 59 vols de radiateur de
refroidissement était effectué un peu
partout en france pour un préjudice
total de 1 million d'euros pour la sncf
et ses sous-traitants